Hello?
Pippo!
Condense everybody!
Condense!
Benz.
Hello.
It's nice to be with you guys.
Yeah.
Missed you both.
I'm excited.
I always miss you.
Yeah.
It's been a while.
More convening adventures today.
Yeah.
I hope you remember how to do our jobs today.
Oh my goodness.
I was just telling them about my newfound combini fav the
creme brulee ice cream yeah you can crack the top like the
top of a creme brulee that oh how creme brulee does it taste
is it very no genuinely quite creme brulee and the crack is
like so satisfying with your spoon and it's like it's so
good guys is it seasonal i don't think so time you guys are
here should be should still be there hopefully hopefully
okay those of you guys that are in japan can go try it go
try it let us know how you like it yeah oh on the other on
the other side of the scale teriyaki chicken pizza no
teriyaki and mayonnaise bread worst thing i've ever eaten in
my life i don't know why it's so bad guys teriyaki and
mayonnaise bread bread okay I thought it would be good.
The teriyaki paste just tastes so weird.
It doesn't taste right.
It's like paste.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
It's so bad, guys.
Oh, you know, I got something last time too.
It was like some sort of like, it was like a soy sauce
cooked corn bread.
And I was like, oh my gosh, this is going to be the amazing,
the best thing ever.
And it was terrible.
It was so, I was like, how do you mess up corn and soy?
sauce i don't understand what it should be a simple
combination yes yeah i don't know what that's about wait
febi you were you were trying to get the mythical um
sprinkle sandwiches but they didn't have right oh i tried so
hard yeah yeah so seven eleven so far like we thought we
thought they were uh april fools joke because they released
on april fools but actually they ended up being real It was
the one from It was like a cream sandwich With rainbow
sprinkles and like pink cream And it was everything I ever
wanted Did you get the perfect cream, Vicky?
No, I didn't I don't really like those sweet sandwiches I
don't know, like sandwiches should be for savory things for
me I don't know, they feel weird I know fruit sando or like
A thing in Japan They have quite a bit of them But I haven't
had too many.
But there was a Pikmin one I had once.
Pikmin.
A Pikmin sandwich?
Oh, no.
Yeah, well, it's not made of Pikmin.
No, it's not made of a Pikmin.
I'll get that.
I end up getting the fruit sand, though, but I always just
eat the inside and I don't eat the bread.
But then you might as well just get, like, a cake with the
same filling, right?
Yeah.
Like, yeah.
But then, but then it's not, uh, it's not like a hundred
fifty yen or whatever it is at, at, at the point.
Oh, true.
Right.
So it's the poor man's cake.
It's a poor man's cake.
That's a big brain.
And I wanted to be the poor man, but I couldn't, I could not
even be the poor man.
I'm the broke man.
Completely broke.
No, no rainbow sprinkle sandwich.
I was so sad.
No.
I was really sad.
I'm gonna write to Mr. 711.
Yeah.
Mr. 711.
Next you're gonna be saying Mr. 711's your uncle or
something.
He better not be because my uncle...
My uncle wouldn't take off the sprinkle bread for you,
sprinkle sandwich.
Yeah, how could they?
Yeah.
They didn't even say when the deadline was.
They did not say.
I feel like I'm going to all the 711s.
I thought your uncle owned those sweeties.
What are they called?
Yeah, the collab, exactly.
When we were trying sweets, IRL, and you were like, it's so
offending, so you were like, oh, that's my uncle.
He does.
And I was like, wait, really?
Yum.
Uncle's got a lot of hands and many pies, it seems
suspicious.
Well, I was saying, his hands before putting his hands in
the pot.
I hope so.
Well, I was saying my uncle shouldn't work at, or I hope
he's not working 7-Eleven because if my uncle worked there
he wouldn't take off the sandwich for people.
No.
Yeah.
For no one.
He wouldn't take that sandwich down for no one.
Yeah.
You tell him.
I feel like though I'll find a sandwich or...
Mm-mm.
Wow.
Did you get the try?
either of you I didn't now oh I didn't want to I wanted you
to try it I didn't want to try did you see it it wasn't real
did we just make it up I've seen it no I see it yeah yeah oh
you saw it okay not when you know when you were here though
unfortunately yeah yeah I did not I feel like you've been
looking for that sandwich for months now like it's been so
yeah I think I think I'll always I'll always have that hope
in my heart because we don't give up but but it's okay I've
made peace with it if I just never ever go if I go my entire
life without having that sandwich it's okay new dreams they
existen they existen yeah and it'll come back it'll come
back I hope so yeah I'm just happy that they lived for a
little bit I'm happy they lived Japan is very like that
though I feel like every time I go, I'll find something that
I really, really love, and it's just gone in two weeks.
And I'm like, why, why, why?
It's so annoying.
Don't get me started on the...
There was this amazing...
Oh my gosh, guys.
It was like chicken tempura udon.
It was literally the best thing I'd ever had from 7-Eleven.
Next day I go, it's gone.
It was literally one day I got to have it, and then it never
came back.
And I was like, oh, that's evil.
Did it even exist?
I think it's more evil that you got to have it once.
Not knowing would be the last time.
I know.
Not knowing.
Oh my gosh.
Sheer ignorance at what would come.
Yeah, it was very, very sad indeed.
Chicken tempura udon.
Yummy.
7-Eleven in Australia was pretty cool, though.
They had, like, sausage rolls.
Yeah.
It's interesting to see another 7-Eleven.
I got Yu-Gi-Oh cards for the 7-Eleven.
You got what cards?
Whoa.
Yu-Gi-Oh cards.
But I haven't opened them yet.
What makes them special?
You could do, like, an opening.
I don't know.
I should do an opening, but it's just one pack.
What makes it special?
I don't know.
I just got them because I was like, I'll remember that I got
these Yu-Gi-Oh cards in Australia.
And then I never opened the pack.
You open them up and they're upside down, and you're like,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa!
The cards were upside down.
It wasn't even legal.
Can I use this competitively?
Whoa!
You open them up and blue, blue ice white dragons like, good
day, mate.
Good day!
There's like an actual like speaker built into the card and
it says that.
Like it's special.
These are some good ideas.
You get a hook on this thing.
Blue eyes, blue eyes, white quaka.
incredible now i want nothing more but the blue ice white
quarker and the and the black rose bin chicken
i love it when you can see those cards like in person you
know when you go to one of those shops that sell them and
you're like oh it's the famed this card and you see them all
lined up so cool Did you guys have any like special cards
like that before or?
Not that I've ever owned, I don't think.
When I was a kid, I had a golden Pikachu card.
It was like thick.
It was like some kind of metal.
Wait, the one from Burger King?
Yeah, but it was in Spanish.
Spanish but it was my treasure like I uh there was this kid
I like like I befriended this kid and he didn't have any
other friends but I befriended him before he moved away and
he gave it to me and I became my treasure it was like I
couldn't read it in Spanish but uh but it was my treasure oh
my god he gave you like yeah he gave you like a real like a
doubloon like a like a pirate I don't think I even realized
I don't even think I realized how Was it rare?
Is it rare?
Oh my god!
What?
Okay, is that just eBay weight inflating?
There's one on eBay for 125,000 yen.
What?
Hold on!
Whoa!
I mean, they were like, they were, they were, they were toys
in like the Burger King happy meals back in the day.
So I mean, they're like, oh my god.
Out of print.
I don't know where mine went.
Whoa, whoa, is eBay being like crazy wacko?
No, I think to be fair, I think eBay does do this.
You look up a thing and you're like, wow, it's worth that
much.
It's totally not.
Like, what was it?
I thought that my beanie babies were like worth loads of
money because eBay told me they were worth loads of money.
Now I was like, wow, I have this like Loch Ness monster
beanie baby with the tag still attached.
I'm not so I thought that about the princess Diana one oh
yeah wait what was the prince Diana beanie baby what
princess they'll make a beanie baby out of any tragedy they
really will there's like a hurricane Katrina beanie baby
holy is that what the what a legacy I'm guessing it was made
before the death no no it's made after that's kind of crazy
Oh, get in following the tragic boss of Diana.
Oh, wait, no, wait.
Sorry, eBay says it's $675, but Walmart says it's 21, 23.
Wow.
Which is it?
I found a jigglypuff for five bucks.
Oh, wow.
If it's the Burger King ones.
I know one wants jigglypuff.
I like those because of the Burger King ones because the
pokeballs felt really authentic So I would play with the
pokeballs and I didn't care about the gold plated item That
sounds fun One of my favorite shorts recently is this oh go
ahead Go ahead go ahead No I just said I'm like I didn't
gift me the pokeball so I never got to experience how
authentic it felt they were in pokeballs?
Why that's so cool yeah they were really nice actually yeah
I was going to say one of my favorite shorts recently is
like jigglypuff I think it was like jigglypuff use and then
insert name of move there's also a song here and then they
sing that song as jigglypuff.
So it was like jigglypuff use last resort and it was like
I wanna see it was so good I will send to you guys after it
was pretty good if I could find it again yeah yeah yeah and
jigglypuff you know Phoebe you give jigglypuff energy yeah
yeah but jigglypuff was like a kind of a little stinker
sometimes I think as well I don't really oh no actually no
jigglypuff just wanted to sing for everyone but just kept
putting them to sleep and then we get mad yeah and i kind of
i kind of get it i get it too they just didn't realize their
power everybody i if i had a pokemon that could put me to
sleep that that'd be amazing just like right i'm not going
to be the only one that bring it with them on a plane yeah
oh my god wait can you imagine like flying in pokemon and
they're just like okay guys It's light out time and then
Sleep They put everyone to sleep They put everyone to sleep
Yes the babies too Oh my god Especially That would be so
nice Wait that would be so awesome I guess the like The the
air hostess would have to wear like Yeah yeah the pilots
will wear earplugs You guys don't worry about it It'll be
like it'll be like the Odyssey Like no we can't be tempted
Tie them up.
The skull kind of went really quickly.
Yeah.
I want to hear the sirens.
Tie me to the pole.
I want to hear it.
Yeah.
Have you guys watched or listened to Epic the Musical?
Not yet.
I really want to.
So good.
ninkle we have to get vicky to listen to it oh it's so good
yeah oh my gosh did you know they're making an animated
movie oh yeah two games or something like that wait games
yeah i didn't hear that games games i didn't hear that wait
that's awesome yeah once it comes out we can all watch it
yeah yeah show me i think i think you guys are saying before
you have like playlists of show me like your fan animations
and stuff my favorite uh favorite animatic of each song so
you can watch oh my gosh i'm so excited it's good it's good
it's also like what how it's like four hours long so that's
really long it's pretty long yeah four hours yeah it's like
hours like Like, when it becomes an actual, like, stage play
musical, then they plan to, like, cut it down.
But right now, he's got, like, a song for almost every
single significant event in the Odyssey.
So...
I hope they don't cut it down too much, though.
I like it.
Yeah, because there's too many good songs.
Like, what would they even cut?
Yeah, exactly.
Everything feels important.
I had so many people recommend it, so I'm very excited.
Bring me, bring me your playlist sometime.
We will watch it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can do it as like a, as a stream if we want to too.
We could.
I think.
Oh, good do.
Good do.
Sounds like a fun idea.
Chat, you want to watch it with us?
Yeah.
Epic the musical!
Watch it out!
Woohoo!
Sounds like a good idea.
I heard from some friends that they liked it better than the
Odyssey movie that just came out.
I've heard that too.
Oh!
oh go ahead oh no no go ahead go ahead i was just gonna say
i think like the songs are just like some of the songs are
so catchy and so good and it does really like cover a good
amount of the story so it's like yeah it's really it's it's
so well done yeah and they chose the best cast for every
character yes i'm excited to take it out because i've seen
i'll just see move that full of was really good so i'm
guessing if i like that also very much like epic the musical
maybe even better yeah i'll have to see yeah cause my
judgment wasn't it like a covet project or i think so it was
like a tick tock musical first
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah tick tock musical thing first yeah
yeah yeah yeah somebody in my chat said that Epic and the
movie do very different things with different goals, but
they would say they enjoyed Epic more.
Oh.
Oh, interesting.
I think you'll love it.
I want to see Robert Pattinson, though.
Oh, I love it.
And then you want to see it.
He like, he plays the, he plays the evil guy.
Who was Robert Pattinson in the movie?
Oh, he's the evil guy.
The evil guy.
Yeah.
Is he one of the suitors in the castle or something?
Yes, the main suitor.
Yes, yes.
He keeps, in interviews, he keeps, like, defending his
character.
He's like, oh, yeah, you know, he's a pretty good guy.
Yeah, you know, he's a pretty good option for Penelope.
It's like gaslighting.
No, I love Rob Patterson, though.
I think he's, like, my favorite, like, actor at the moment.
I just, I don't know.
I just think he's really good.
really good he's really good and he's so like committed to
like his roles and stuff i think that's what makes him yeah
such a great actor yeah oh pat's an appreciation club i know
have you guys seen his interviews like like about twilight
some of them i don't think so they make me laugh so much
because he's just kind of like he's just like how do you
just kind of like what what was even going on like very
confused about the movies and everything yeah he's like
watching the clips where he's like stifering back laughter
during the scenes of twilight it's like something really
serious is going on with better and he's just like
It feels like he's like...
See, that just goes to show how good of an actor he was,
though.
He was able to keep a straight face.
Exactly.
I know.
Twilight behind the scenes are so good, though.
Like, watching Kristen Stewart having to pet...
What's his name?
Taylor Lawton, or...
When he's, like, in a mocap suit.
He's supposed to be a wolf, but he's just a man.
Wait!
I didn't know that!
I don't...
I assume there'd be something to stand in for the CGI.
No, it would have been...
They would have been...
Oh my god.
They would think...
You would think they would do that, but no, they just...
They just kept him in the suit for...
No, I don't know.
I'm like kind of confused why, because like, you don't need
him to, like, face act or anything for it.
So it's just kind of funny.
No!
Right?
I bet they were like, oh yeah, she'll be able to get into
character way more if we put Everyone's got a freaking
Taylor Modner in a mocap suit in front of her so she can
gaze into his beautiful eyes No, that's the worst part is
he's like head down like hunched over like Looking like
Smeagle
Wow, oh my gosh Is it spoilers if I say I literally watched
the final Twilight movie for the first time like a couple of
weeks ago can i talk about it or is that spoiled oh wait
please i i haven't seen the very last one yet but but but
but i pretty much know what happened so it's okay from the
books just go ahead go ahead i don't want to spoil it for
you though if you're gonna watch it does it do something
special is the movie um special is one word for it yeah i
mean one way of saying it The best part of any of the movies
happens and it doesn't even happen.
It has.
It broke me insane.
Wait, what?
So they have this like, this like really epic fight scene,
right, Phoebe?
And it's like, wow, finally getting some actions.
The best part of all the movies, like main characters are
dying.
It's like actual stuff is happening.
And I'm like, wow, it's really picking up the pace.
It was like really crazy.
And then it was all the vision.
That was all the vision of what would have happened.
None of it actually happened.
So you go down this hall, like, how long was it meant to,
like, 30, 40 minutes at least?
Yes, yes, yes.
Like, it was a very long drawn out.
Like, it was the Voltori versus everybody.
It was, like, the Avengers happening.
And it was, like, whoa.
Like, I think Carlisle, like, gets his head ripped off.
And you're like, oh, my God, what are they going to do?
And then it, like, just zooms out from Alice's eye.
And she was like, oh, my God, that would be crazy.
if that happened.
It was such a troll.
I was like, oh my god.
I wonder what the reaction in the theater was at that time.
I want to see a video.
I don't think people would be pleased.
Everyone just collectively groans.
It was all a dream.
All a dream.
Happy birthday to B.
favorite chair happy birthday what a name wow to be's
favorite chair happy birthday oh man i would like to be to
be second favorite chair that would be great you guys can
fight for the yeah fight for the for the title oh no they
can take number one it's their birthday oh that's true it's
okay yeah Oh, that's so kind.
No special days.
Take it.
And then...
And then we got 50 Shades of Grey.
What?
Why are we talking about that now?
Because that was a Twilight fanfiction.
Woofair!
Yeah!
Yes, actually.
50 Shades of Grey started as a Twilight fanfiction.
they had to change all the names because you couldn't have
him be edward and
that's a hundred percent true that's a hundred percent true
i have not seen it but i've heard things about this movie is
it should i should i watch it probably not right is it what
would you even call it twilight the office au yeah i guess
so right because like you know actually i don't even really
quite know what 50 shades is about i just know that they do
the sexy yeah like it's it's all about like well it's
because like the colons are so rich i guess they're like oh
what if edward was a rich businessman ceo mr man and um i
don't i don't remember what it's even about it sounds like
half the k dramas i've seen it really is it's everything oh
yeah oh my god rich business man yeah it's always the way it
is rich business man falls in love with his assistant or
something poor girl yeah poor girl something like that yes
why a mortal movie was that 50 shades read through a denser
suit uh no no no i don't we'll be doing that no no no go
read it yourself
oh my god i'll be edward that's crazy knowledge i don't know
what his name is you'll be edward oh okay is jacob in it or
no actually i don't think so i don't think i don't remember
oh okay wow they just this is jacob erasure i have they
hated But, but, you guys, were you, were you on a team as a
child at all?
Like, you know, when people were on Team Edward and Team
Jacob?
Or were you, were you, did you have a faction?
I did, but I think only because, I mean, it was the case
with all these things.
I sort of pretended to like these things, even though I'd
never read the books, and I didn't really pay attention in
the movie.
So I just pretended I was Team Jacob, because he was the one
who didn't get enough, like, support.
yeah I'm team Jacob just to kind of give him some that was
exactly how I read them because my all my friends were into
it and I was like okay I guess I gotta read Twilight no see
I was like oh there's a book club at school but the book
club is specifically for the book series Twilight oh I guess
I gotta read it yeah everyone was like are you team Edward
or team Jacob and I was like oh guess I gotta pick one I
love the movies now though I love them they're so funny at
the time it was like oh I don't understand what's going on
and I don't want to like pretend to like something and now
I'm like they're so good in their own way like great great
movies yeah I gotta rewatch then they're so funny they're
like so horribly awkward and silly i don't know who i was
though i think i was team edward but i didn't like either of
them so i don't know what's the dad called i'm team the dad
charlie yeah team charlie he's great yeah re-watching
twilight is realizing how much he was so like yeah he didn't
deserve all of that oh my god oh yeah my friend's a werewolf
i'm a vampire don't tell anyone okay as long as i can still
see my daughter i know that's the real one that's the real
one charlie oh oh yeah nothing bad happens to the dad right
no no luckily no okay But every time I was like, nothing,
Ben, nothing happened to him.
I don't know.
He was stressed a lot, though.
Where you get to, like, you get to, like, look up if
something bad happens to the dog in the movie.
Does the dog die?
Dot com.
Or something like that.
Oh, yes, yes.
The dad does.
Dot com.
No.
We need something like that.
Yeah.
I haven't heard of it.
Does the dog die?
I've heard of, can you pet the dog?
Can?
Yeah, that's also a good website.
Yeah, that one's good.
Can you pet the dog?
talking of pets oh my god the little chicao cat bed so cute
yeah i got gifted i got gifted a chicao cat bed hold on i
can link my tweet what yeah and so i've been holding on to
it for forever now i was like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna get
my cat my oh it'll be for your cat oh yeah wait can i show
getting this guy yeah i want to make sure he doesn't get
adopted hold on here's here it is the oh yeah yeah we're
gatekeeping yeah sorry everybody i'll share pictures once i
get him but for now oh it's such a good chico bed oh i want
one for myself look yeah i can imagine you crawling up in
here Phoebe I know probably I might be able to maybe look at
this dummy dumb's little face I love his little tail and his
little eyes he's like cross-eyed a little he looks so
serious I love that about him so cute yet serious Yeah, like
serious business You can't tell in the pictures, but he's
like massive He's really like bulky like a muscle man But I
love him He's so sweet I hope I can get him Aw Fingers
crossed, fingers crossed I crossed Crossing the holes,
crossing fingers I hope he would love you He'd love you I
hope so.
I want to love him.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, crossing everything for you for it that it works out.
Speaking of pets, are we ready to go see our dog?
Wait, what do we have again?
Our dogs?
Yeah, I've got a dog.
What do you have again, Phoebe?
A dog.
And a puppy.
Yeah.
It's been a bit since we played this game.
All right, let's start.
I don't remember.
Oh, goodbye, everybody.
Two ducks and a dog.
It's like homeward bound.
Yeah, welcome in, guys.
We're just now starting.
Yeah, we're just now starting.
It's a new night.
New night.
We can go behind the counter.
Okay.
I don't remember anything.
Okay, we got gas.
Oh, I remember to pick up the coins.
I remember these.
I remember the coins guy.
I remember the gacha.
Yeah.
Yeah, we got the gun.
You got new permanent doppel detection hardware.
This is the anomaly lens.
Oh, use it to inspect customers.
If the screen reveals any anomalies or differences from
reality, the customer is a doppelganger.
You're recommended to briefly scan every customer with the
anomaly lens.
Okay.
Anomaly lens.
Money, money, money.
Very convenient.
Um...
Why can't we access the computer yet?
Oh, no?
Oh, oh, maybe it doesn't start until we start the shift.
Oh, did everybody read the note?
Oh, I'll read it.
I'll read it.
It says two out of three behind the counter.
There we go.
I read it now.
Okay, nice.
Wait, we still can't use the computer?
Yeah, what the heck?
What's weird?
Oh, there it goes.
There it goes.
It's on.
Nice!
I'm picking up coins.
Oh, we got mail.
We got a $70 quota.
Oh no.
This is an official warning from Neat.
Oh sorry, Net.
Jack in the box, music box has recently been spotted near
the entity.
Oh, if you see it, rewind the music box immediately.
Do not allow the song to finish three times.
Okay.
Is this good?
Okay, hello.
Hello there.
I scanned her.
She's an optometrist and she requires glasses.
Does she have glasses on?
She's got glasses on.
What was that?
Movements.
What was that sound?
Yeah, did you hear that?
What sound?
This constant beeping sound that...
Oh, I don't hear that.
Wait, I heard like a...
Oh, we've got...
We've got rats!
Hold on, can I use this?
Oh, is that what it is?
Are we...
Are we happy to bag stuff for this lady?
I think we are, right?
I think she seems fine.
I don't...
Seems fine to me.
Oh, I can grab it.
Uh, what do I do with you?
Oh!
Um...
What happened there?
Nothing good.
Nothing, nothing.
Um...
I don't hear it, no.
Yeah, I think she was fine.
Okay, oh.
It's like every time I'm right here.
Weird.
Oh, it's the sheriff!
It's the sheriff!
He's here!
Oh, it's a fat dog!
Yeah, he's nice.
Oh, where'd you get a burger?
I found it here!
Well, like, what do I do?
You should eat it.
I should eat it?
Oh.
I don't think I can.
Oh, hello, sir.
So sorry to keep you waiting.
Nice to meet you, bug.
Wait, bug.
Nice to meet you.
We've met you a lot.
Yeah, we've met you a ton of times.
Wait, no.
Don't tell me that.
We in, like, a time.
What's happening?
Wait, I remember!
He looks normal on this anomaly lens.
I'm glad.
Yeah, he does, isn't he?
Go around the back of him.
Maybe his ass is an anomaly.
I remember when we first started the game, he was like the
first guy that came in.
So it wouldn't be like...
Because we just had that other lady.
It's not like the game restarted.
Right?
Yeah, yeah.
You think suspicious then?
I don't know.
He said nice to meet you.
Right?
I think so.
Weird.
It is weird.
Hold on.
I don't want to shoot him.
I don't want to kill him.
He's our friend.
Hi, you.
Strange thing you ask a man you just met.
I think it is.
I think because we have not just met him.
First time meeting me, so I'll spell it out.
Sheriff uniform.
He's not good.
Yeah, kill him.
Yeah, he keeps saying first time meeting.
Yeah, we gotta do it.
Who's gonna do it?
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, I hear him!
What?
Norbert!
Hey!
Oh, sorry.
He scared me.
Oh.
Do we have to kill him?
Yeah, we have to kill him.
Norbert, come back.
Norbert.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Ah, Bert!
Until you bring us some more lemonade.
I'm just beating up the meat.
I'm beating the meat.
Oh, we got a car.
We got a car.
You are what?
Okay.
Just coming back for my student soccer game.
Easy win.
Junior bears don't lose.
I take like $18 a gas, thanks.
The junior bears don't lose.
Wait, we got to investigate.
there was the flashlight we got a oh here it is I've got it
oh your inventory is full how do I drop star uh G oh G G G
baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby this guy has a
list of uh people
that oh look we've got a line up license do we need to check
the shirts we've got Lucius Gabrielle Tanner.
Wait, where's his license plate?
FJ88.
90% sure.
FJ80.
Left headlight is dimmer than the right.
Oh, it is!
It is!
Left headlight's a little bit dimmer.
I've been meaning to get it fixed.
I think this guy's good.
These are the Junior Bears' jerseys.
tell me they just left them lying around back there that's
the lineup of the mighty junior bears just finished driving
them all home are we not suspect how many shirts are there
there's one two there's five shirts five names do we need to
check the names no right I don't think surely not I think
it's okay or you think so oh wait that's a good idea though
right what if they're all dead I'm gonna look up Ray Hamlet
Ray Hamlet Ray Hamlet
He's dead!
He killed them all!
Death mutilation!
Kill him, kill him!
I got him.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Oh, uh oh, we got a phone call.
Oh, I like how the car just phases out of the car.
Mushy, Mushy.
I'm answering.
Rise and shine, knucklehead, it's the boss.
I hope you're enjoying another peaceful normal night.
But because apparently the store is now allergic to peaceful
normal nights.
No, we got roaches!
We got roaches!
No!
Get the roaches!
What are you waiting for, Goal?
I'll give you a damn bonus.
Okay.
What do we use on them?
I'm using the...
What's it?
Yeah, you can use a mop.
Hold on.
I'm killing them.
Don't worry, I'm killing them good.
I'm killing them good.
Come on bud!
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Get out of here, get out of here!
Where are the roaches?
Where are they?
Wait, there's just one more, there's just one more!
Oh, I see him, I see him!
I go.
Yay!
Good job!
Nice!
Ha, ha, uh...
You!
You?
Oh, there are like four more roaches.
I kept smacking them.
Oh, gross.
You.
Me?
Be a part of our story.
I was going to go over the walls in the bathroom.
We are.
I was going to go for Soldier Boy, but sure, that's you.
Me?
You.
MVP up in this.
Oh.
I can't stop going you.
Me?
This is like my.
it's like my what's that word vocal stem now yeah oh i'm
already full why on earth did the calendar killer not strike
last night oh i don't know whole thing was eight people on
the eighth of every month he's done it for the past six
months is he dead i have to look further into it i don't
know i don't know man victor hale what if we were the
calendar killer us wait how do i use thing wait what you
like you click and then you scan him he seems fine yeah he
seems fine
oh wow there's a bunch of meat outside i think i think i
think he's die-jobu are we happy that he's die-jobu oh oh
thank you you better not be lying to us oh i think maybe
it's better if we yeah like that yeah we don't have to take
out the trash oh we got a running man Go running, man.
Running, running, running, running, running, running.
Oh.
Hey there, boss.
Hope your night's going smoothly.
Don't call me boss unless I know you.
Postal worker jogs everywhere always wears his orange jacket
shown in ID.
The calendar killer was a child that you all saw.
Been doing rounds for years.
A child?
The jacket is wrong.
You were wearing something different.
The logo was on the left side.
instead of the right side.
It is!
Yeah!
I just, I'm just stuck in the shelves and I see bangs or I
hear bangs from right behind me.
Don't worry about it, Phoebe.
Just a normal day in the office.
That's a normal, normal day.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
I spilled much of spaghetti sauce and much marinaro.
A spaghetti sauce.
spaghetti sauce pizza alright you look a little shaken oh
who are I think this is a new lady Vanessa McCree don't mind
me just having a little bit of gacha fix oh good new hat
guys oh nice farmer hat this lady's name is Vanessa but her
signature says Vanny you think that's okay non-human task
I'm a sergeant I got a leader It's more like it.
I feel more like home now.
Christ, you cleaned up cards over.
Yay.
It could have been more reddish too.
Vanny.
Oh.
Oh, nice hat.
Does she seem okay?
Vanny's okay.
I think so.
She seems all right.
Okay.
Vanny.
Maybe it's find them.
Vanessa McCree, I would say Vanessa McCree is okay.
All right.
I'll accept the transaction.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, look at this guy!
Superman!
Save us!
What happened?
What just happened?
was it did we let the jack-in-the-box do something or
something like that is there jack-in-the-box around I don't
I didn't hear anything don't be alarmed the star defender
has arrived for his usual provisions who are you who are you
hold on sir I gotta clean this up to do anything about that
thing in front of it okay I checked outside no
jack-in-the-boxes thank you oh good hello here
Nolan.
Nolan Sterling.
Occupation unemployed.
Oh.
He's a full-time superhero.
Yeah, listen.
People just don't recognize that as a job yet.
You know, it's like...
It's like full-time VTuber, full-time superhero.
We gotta let this guy do his thing, you know?
It does say superhero fanatic.
So he's just an otaku, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think he's fine.
There's one more roach.
Kill me.
Get him.
Where'd you go?
I think he's okay.
No age limit for saving the world.
I love him.
We'll keep him.
Keep him.
Yeah.
We'll fight for you.
For all otaku.
Yeah.
We're still one of you.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
Burn it on.
Hey!
Who?
Oh my god.
What?
Hey,
where are the, what's the wood?
I put up one.
Don't forget to grab weapons.
Oh, yes.
Oh, I have these too.
Come find them, dude.
I said, do we have more wood for the back?
I don't see any.
No, I don't see either.
Okay, we got a trap there at least.
Oh, jeez.
Who was it?
I need to restock the shelves.
Must resist stocking shelves.
Resist stocking the shelves!
That was not the time!
That's the true reason the entity's here.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, oh
What the heck is that?
Where's the music box?
Oh, where's the music box?
No, I'm unwind it's in the toilet It's in the toilet Oh,
shoot Oh
my god
another one Oh,
I found like where is it?
I got it
What a what?
What a shift!
Woohoo!
That is clean all this!
I know, my goodness gracious.
Who did we let out?
Yeah, who could have been?
I am very intrigued to find out the reasoning.
Me too.
Does anyone have a the bat?
Where's the bat though?
Oh, is that what is the bag?
back oh money guys guys I don't mean to alarm you but
there's a evil man on our bus oh you are so powerful oh is
there any more is there any more Ow, I just walked in a
trap.
No!
Okay, right.
Thank you so much for the raid.
Was it Toffee?
I think he was Toffee.
Thank you for the raid!
I didn't let him out.
Okay.
I hope you're well.
I thought I saw something running over there.
One more for the...
Where'd you see it?
I think it was just my imagination, though.
One more.
Dang it, I wanted a new hat.
What were you doing?
Did you give you money at least?
It did give me money.
Oh good.
I love your nose.
What do I look like?
I have actually no idea.
You've got a little you got a cute little red nose.
Boopable little nose.
Oh my gosh, I like your tongue, Vicky.
Thank you.
Yo-Kai style.
Yeah.
Do you like my hat?
I like your hat.
I love it.
Thank you.
It's the hat of my people.
Okay, I guess we're good to go home then.
We getting on the bus?
Head home?
Yeah.
Oh, good job, right.
Good job, team.
Who was it?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, who was it?
Yeah, who the heck?
Who could it have been?
Oh, we got some good profit tonight, though.
Ooh!
No humans killed.
Okay, that's good.
Oh.
And who did we let?
$20 check!
Let's go!
Yippee!
Yeah.
Was it Vanessa?
Yay!
Was it her?
A bill comes in the mail for the next three days of
medicine.
Oh!
Pay the bill for...
Hey, Bill.
Yippishuki!
Yay!
Gris.
Aww.
Oh, yes!
Ah, that's a strength and joy!
Yay!
We can see you one.
Next letter, it reads, Come see me tomorrow.
Goose won't get better unless we take extreme measures.
It is signed by the veterinary clinic.
Suki!
I shouldn't have named this pet, Suki.
It's just making me sad.
Wait, the anomaly lens.
It was the first lady.
Aria.
We looked over there.
with the lens though didn't we i didn't he definitely did uh
i did oh okay well it's my fault then but i did it there was
nothing there see this means that you're accepting of all
people no matter their anomalies yeah maybe it was like her
feet maybe i didn't look at her feet or something oh yeah i
didn't do it so oops what do you mean we shot that poor guy
everybody that we that we it said we yeah no humans killed
no humans killed everybody Vanessa died of uh of something
else Vanessa died of the the dentist yeah the dentist the
dentist all right we'll use the lens if well sometimes the
lens isn't always available we'll be more careful with the
lens i'm sorry if that was my oh oh they are ready for work
they are so they're like lock in you yeah lock in lock in
pocket all the cash guys pocket all the money pocket the
money okay okay i'm grabbing money first riots begin let's
travel down continue whoa there's um i don't need to alarm
you guys but uh we've got company out what was that Oh, I
think that was a pet.
You've got company outside?
Yeah, we've got company outside.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, there was just one of him before he'd been biting his
family this time.
Everybody's here.
Don't worry, guys.
It's like a...
It's just a cosplay group.
They're just having their photo shoot.
Don't worry.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my gosh.
We're going to get such business today.
Yeah.
If you guys are hungry, we've got everything inside.
We do.
Inside.
It's odd.
Any more money?
Any more money, money?
Money, money?
Oh, here, I'll go read the board, sorry.
What did it say?
Riots begin.
Oh, there was some travel bans between the U.S.
and Europe.
Oh, no!
How will we see each other?
Oh, there's a car.
A car?
Okay.
Hi.
A taxi.
Oh, money.
I thought it was cheese.
$10 of gas.
Oh, let's get the anomaly scanner.
New creature.
Oh, just these.
Cheers.
So we have a guaranteed entity attack, everybody.
Just be ready.
There's nothing in her boot.
Is that suspicious?
Hey, you have hair now.
I might get the anomaly detector on the boot.
What are you asking about the hair?
It grew back.
You refer to that as photosynthesis.
Okay, this guy's a...
Sorry!
Don't mind it!
The animals are eating the meat.
Don't worry about it.
They enjoy it.
They thrive.
They've...
Oh, an email.
An actual plant.
Ooh, pretty string lights.
Let's see.
What do we got?
We've got ramen.
We've got cereal.
Ramen?
Nice.
Delivery, what'd you get?
We got a bubble head.
Oh, yeah!
Wait, did they have...
Did they have wood planks on that thing?
Because we could use that for sure.
Unfortunately, no.
But I did get a lemon.
A lemon?
Guys, what year are we meant to be in?
been to being in this game i think it's the 90s 1993 oh okay
i think she's fine then wait did you check the license plate
yeah rg please it said 1997.
okay rgb wait 97.
red display expiring 1997.
oh expiring 1995.
oh okay okay yeah oh clean exterior Should we check if it's
clean?
It looks clean to me.
So if you have a dirty car, then you're not a real human.
Did you check the inside with the flashlight on?
Oh, yeah.
I did, and there was nothing in there, which makes me
incredibly suspicious.
Why is this so little happening?
This looks fine to me.
I'm doing the anomaly thingy.
Still nothing.
Oh, we do have the anomaly thingy.
Nice.
I'll bring my inside.
No, I think it is just a simple case.
A step on it.
Seems suspicious.
Yeah, I got it.
You got it?
Oh, thank you.
I think she's good, then.
Check the engine?
Oh, wait, we have to check the engine?
Wait!
There's no engine!
Um...
Oh, yes, I misplaced this car's engine.
I'm off to pick up a new one tomorrow morning.
Death killer!
Killer!
Oh my gosh my chat chat good job chat.
Oh my god.
Good job chat.
I forgot you could check the hood Oh my god.
Yeah killer nice Pets The pets will take care of that feast
feast.
Yeah Nice
Wow, yeah back cedars rejoice What's But um, but um, what is
that?
Oh, it's the it's the email.
Oh, yeah, there's an email.
Okay.
I bought us all extra HP, by the way.
Oh, thank you.
I'm gonna refresh the shop even.
Maybe we can get more.
Oh, rat.
Oh, blood moon means an entity attack is guaranteed.
Great.
Yeah.
Just what we wanted.
Okay, hello.
Impact nades.
Okay, I'd like to scan you with the anomaly thing.
What was that?
Thank you.
Up here.
La la la la.
I bought also a security thing, so just in case somebody
steals, we can shoot them.
Or turn- no, don't shoot them.
I think you turn them into the police, actually.
Nice.
plant oh are we looking up this person sorry lady I think I
think this person is fine but I also checked with the
anomaly thingy and there didn't seem to be any problems but
if you guys want to check once as well with the anomaly
tablet I don't even know what to look she's all right yeah
and even why alive
I've been
Why are they talking about, what's she talking about this
guy?
Less Harris, less to worry about.
David, heart attack.
Yeah.
If we come across a David.
Maybe, yeah, David.
David butters?
There's a David butters that's deceased.
David butters.
I think this lady is good though.
I think we're okay.
No, I think she's okay.
Hey guys, look, I'm Lord Leiter.
Thank you.
You've even got the green shirt, too.
I know.
Oh, I'll get the car.
I'll get the...
Coolidig's friend.
You're not my friend.
May I please have $16 of gas?
Already suspicious calling us friends.
Oh, F2.
Wait, is that the...
Hold on, I'm gonna double check.
What's that luggage?
There's luggage in there.
FF2.
1995, 1988.
black station wagon okay black station wagon where's
he going why is this purple
what's his name i had a work trip overseas um he hasn't said
yeah what's his name uh did it say um ff2 Wait.
LFF2.
That doesn't say, I guess we...
Oh wait!
There was a travel ban!
Oh yeah!
Good plan!
Was it all travel?
It was just between the US and Europe.
Yeah, wait.
It was just, I'm coming back from the airport, I have a work
trip overseas.
He doesn't say where though.
It was only...
It was only Europe, no?
yeah Europe and the United States yeah so how we didn't how
do we know where did you come from I wish we could ask yeah
where'd you come from hmm it's I suppose we have no reason
to think that he is suspicious at this point right what did
I guess don't like do do like that maybe we take him out
just in case yeah maybe i'll get the gun oh my god sorry sir
yeah i think that was the right choice he said he came from
a work trip overseas oh yeah there's a ban right now on
sunday i know that'll get you killed man it'll get you
killed specifics to kill oh blah blah blah how's it going hi
corey uh you are corey bishop corey i like his id is him
wearing his id when he was wearing his id yeah intern
journalist oh interesting
here's a satchel yeah he does oh i'll look at him in this
thing frequently asks questions Because he's a journalist.
He is asking quite a bit of questions.
Okay, he seems fine.
On the scanner.
That's good.
IDception.
So funny.
I wonder if that one of the ID also has an ID with the ID.
Yeah, right?
That's what it looks like.
I guess he's fine.
Hmm.
He seems okay.
frequently asked questions how's it going what was it he
doesn't ask many questions i think he's been asking quite a
bit of questions i think he's been asking questions yeah i
think it's okay all right all right i'll accept him i'll
accept go yeah i agree i think he's probably okay i think he
was okay i think he was okay
Whoa.
Love the fish.
Wow.
Imagine doing this to somebody in real life.
I sure hope you're an actual human.
Quiet night, isn't it?
Ah!
She's not free.
Um.
She's not.
Oh.
Whoa, my jeepish.
I got her.
How dare you?
How dare you jump scare us?
That is rude.
What's the phone say?
On to the phone.
What's it saying?
What?
We know you are kind.
We know you.
Come into forest.
Wait!
I think it's those guys!
I think it's the guys!
I like them.
Yeah, the cosplay shoot, people.
Yeah, they seem pretty cool.
What was that?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that was, don't worry about it.
Good.
I'm going to do one more gotcha.
They know we are kind.
Is that what it said?
Duck on the head!
I want the duck!
Oh, my God.
That's so cute.
All right, guys.
Oh.
Head to the forest behind the storm.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Should we grab a flashlight?
I'm gonna go grab a flashlight.
Yeah.
That's a good idea.
We just have one?
Yeah.
No, we have a couple.
There is a...
There's a guy in just shorts.
No shirt, no shoes, no service.
No service.
Yeah, you can grab a flashlight right here, Phoebe.
Oh, where?
Oh, out there?
Yeah.
Where are they?
We're here, we're here.
Is there any more?
Yeah, yeah, there's infinite.
Any more flashlights or just two?
No, it's just on the wall right here.
Oh, you think?
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
Yep, let's go.
Okay.
Where are we going again?
Oh, to the forest.
I'm gonna move this, though.
Okay.
Here we go.
We ain't scared, don't we?
There he is!
Explore the forest.
I see one.
Wait, he's gone?
Hello?
Should we have brought weapons?
Oh.
Oh, what's that, Sarah?
That's something.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, there's like a ritual going on here.
Wow.
Should we pick up the ritual?
Wow, look at this!
What is this?
Ow!
poured in in here i'm trying oh nice oh i see is this
norbert's lemonade that we're pouring we're some summoning
norbert i see them in the distance and they run away i think
there's some here is this more are you running oh it
wouldn't let me pick it up though oh maybe bucket yeah yeah
yeah yeah probably oh is your HP okay is your HP okay yeah
don't worry I'm still good okay okay we can we can do it if
you want yeah we can do the next one don't worry about it
like okay yes please I'm looking around oh I'll just carry
the bucket oh oh Oh, maybe around here somewhere?
No?
Is that what I...
Oh, I'm seeing...
Okay, just one.
Hello?
I hear people coming for service.
I know, right?
I'm not going to get it.
Oops.
They don't know we're playing around in the woods.
What?
Oh, what was that?
Yes.
Yeah, it's weird noises.
Is this it?
Here's the bucket.
You got it, Vicky?
What the heck?
Oh.
I just dropped the bucket.
Wait, it might have spawned back here.
Let me try.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, nice.
Now this way.
Nice.
All right.
Having a little picnic in the woods, lovely.
Oh, ouch.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, spicy.
Ooh, it's so spicy.
Ooh, is that the spicy?
That's spicy, right?
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Oh.
here we go yeah oh hello oh hi we're friends we're friends
hi guilt born thank you oh thank you oh no problem um what
does that mean guilt born i guilt born i don't know but they
seem they seem to like us are we guilty wait oh i got like a
thing wait why are these here oh Why are the tablets here?
Did you guys...
I dropped on the floor, sorry.
Oh, okay, okay.
I needed to clear my inventory.
I was like, oh, they're iPad babies.
Yeah, that's what I thought too.
That's what they mean by guilds for.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I heard some...
I heard a customer.
Oh, whoops, at the store.
Whoops.
Yeah, we are on the job.
Oh, I am so sorry, you guys.
My bad.
Holy moly.
Sorry, the pets have been holding it down.
How's that station right here?
Look, they left us hearts, you guys!
Look, they left us a heart!
Oh my god!
That's so cute!
They're so cute!
Aww!
That's very kind.
That is, I'm gonna go spend their money.
So kind.
Oh hi, sorry, my bad.
Ricky Lawson.
A stash.
Oh yeah, we've seen that guy.
Oh, it's stash.
Ricky Barton?
Oh my god, I'm a big fan.
Oh, God.
No, okay.
He's a college dropout.
See, it's twice as much as us.
See, it's twice exactly two packs of cookies.
Did he get two packs of cookies?
I'm sorry.
I think we have to kill him.
Why?
Because he didn't buy two packs of cookies.
But his birthday's six, seven.
I think we might have to.
Wait, when did you become...
When are you an anti-
He's got a lazy eye.
He's too suspicious.
Where's the two packs of cookies?
He doesn't have any.
That's why we're gonna have to kill him.
Switten it up tonight.
Gotta keep life interesting.
I don't think he's that kind of person.
Why would they put it in his bio if he did that?
Yeah.
It's my running fit.
Very suspicious.
He called our car a shitbox car.
Oh, what?
Rude?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think we got to kill him.
Wait, did we scan him?
Did we scan him?
Yeah, I did.
It didn't seem to be anything weird.
But it's the cookies that are making me doubt.
But it's as usual.
It's always.
That's true.
I do remember his scenes are being Rickatron 3000 when he
came before.
Oh, yeah.
I remember that too.
I think he's okay.
I think he's...
Boss!
What a threat!
Oh my god!
Wow!
Snake!
Oh!
Wait, we gotta get this guy out of here so we can, uh...
Maybe he'll buy something.
Wait, he just littered on the floor.
This is... this is...
Snake!
that dude you have one mostly five star reviews but just one
four star review i think the staff were ogling me but still
a nice little store were you guys ogling the customers never
never never never never no never never never i was not
ogling the goth lady i don't know i don't know what to do
about this one I think I'm probably okay but that would be
my opinion what do you think Phoebe maybe he's all right
because he's changing it up for today oh I don't know I
don't know either is there are there any packs of cookies in
here is this a pack of cookies
That would be so silly if that was the reason why he's not
human is because he's not buying two packs, right?
I don't know.
Wait, you don't have a car?
Wait, what did he talk about?
Where did he talk about our car?
Oh, uh, he said it in his clothes.
It's got more miles than your shitbox car.
Oh, he just says I bet.
I don't think he's, I think he's just insulting us to be a
weirdo.
I don't know.
I think he's just annoying, but I think he's...
Oh, check his eye.
He's supposed to have a lazy eye.
He does have it.
He does have it, yeah.
Okay.
I think he probably is okay then.
But suspicious.
Everyone is suspicious.
I know.
It doesn't have two cookies.
Usually being the keyboard.
That's the thing, though, is usually it's not always.
Yeah The the writing is confusing
I think he's okay.
Okay, all right.
He's just as annoying as he is typically.
Okay, I'll I'll get him then.
I'll say it's okay Um, put some trousers on what what?
No, he's there one thing he can just go in here.
Whoa.
Oh, this guy's I don't know.
Oh, no, the blood moon calls.
The blood moon calls.
Okay, so maybe we were right Alright then.
Yeah, maybe.
NC has been alerted.
Actually, I'm gonna put...
Oh, you guys.
Okay.
Grab your weapons and the landmine.
I'm gonna put the landmine.
Oh, did someone...
Oh, here we go.
Watch out for the landmine.
Okay.
We have some grenades that we have here.
We have some grenades, yeah.
Hey.
Oh.
Wait, do we not get weapons?
Uh-oh.
Yeah, it said it almost later.
On later.
Do you want to put, like, a few traps?
Oh, no.
Any of the doors?
We got stuff on the doors, yeah.
Oh, there is still our gun.
I got...
There's another gun over here if someone wants to grab it.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, here on the ground right there.
Someone's already holding the gun.
Wait.
There's two, though.
Try grabbing it now?
There we go.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Got it, got it.
I will raw dog.
Oh, screw you.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
Oh no.
Uh oh, I went to the lab behind that.
Where is it?
It's in the main room.
What was I dying to?
Oh, guns!
Oh, we got the guns!
I was trying to find it, yeah!
What the hell is that?
Kill a marionette.
Oh!
Nice!
Yay!
We did it.
Good job, guys.
Good job.
Yeah, easy peasy.
All right, let's clean up that tomato ketchup off the floor.
There we go.
Nothing to see here.
Real quick, my expressions are frozen.
Oh, no.
Let's...
I miss those guys from outside.
They were really nice, you know?
Yeah, they were...
I think they looked scary, but they were really friendly.
I really like them.
to wait isn't today we see the vet them to come back oh
there's oh yeah let's hope we have enough money huh i know
oh whoa that's a lot of explosion yeah well it'll clean up
itself yeah oh nice oh
I think that would have been a, that would have been like a
three-pointer.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, it was a nice throw.
A game-winning shot.
Yeah.
Are we good to go then?
I think so.
I think we're good to go.
All right, let's go, team.
Please, may the vets be not too expensive.
Yeah.
Please.
10 out of 13 complete.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh guys, we only got three nights left.
Yeah, we can do this.
No humans killed!
We did it!
Awesome!
You arrive at the vest- oh, as instructed.
Oh, number- Oh!
Oh!
Surgery!
That sounds expensive.
It does sound expensive.
$250!
three days remain 250 dollar bill we don't I thought we
would have that much but we don't shoot to do we just take
money from everyone even if we know they're double down
maybe at this point yeah yeah I don't know I mean we're
pretty good on surviving the attack so maybe it's okay yeah
right maybe it's okay yeah Wait, it said the driver claims
to have arrived from France, but he didn't say that.
He didn't say that?
He did not say that.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Okay.
Well, you guys were right on...
It's a new night.
Check the notice board.
Oh!
I don't mean to alarm you guys, but there is a dentist on
our roof.
Ah!
Oh, oh!
Where?
I scared him off.
Oh, I think I scared him.
Yeah, I scared him off.
I said boo and he ran.
He ran like a little puppy.
Yeah, yeah, that was him.
I love finding the coins.
Yeah, right?
So fun.
Any friends out here?
Any friends?
No friends.
Sims.
We got a lot of friends yesterday.
Yeah.
What's going on?
The midnight news.
Fire engulfs Parkside Plaza.
Parkside Plaza caught fire early today leaving the building
badly damaged crews fought the blaze for hours before
bringing it under control Okay Parkside Plaza Parkside Plaza
if anyone says that they've come from Parkside Plaza and
doesn't mention it suspicious Suspicious oh hello John John
VTuber perhaps I'm gonna try and spend the money guys I
think we need to get as many of these ten dollars for ten
bucks oh bunny ears hey did somebody just hey please it's
just food man i'm not some kind of criminal give back the
items steal yeah somebody stole what the heck oh john smith
is a suspicious name do we get the money if we get do we get
a bonus i'm gonna see out right here oh yeah we get ten
dollars we get ten dollars no our five star rating is in
danger why because of troublemakers who try to get your
ratings down apparently since they are human you may not
come in and find any way to annoy other customers
unfortunately since they are humans you may deal non-lethal
damage to them for example throwing toilet paper at them
okay oh was he good I mean, he looks okay, but John Smith
and working with spreadsheets, I don't know, it seems
suspicious to me.
Does seem a little suspicious.
If you see any troublemakers, I put toilet paper on the
table.
Oh, thanks!
Good, good.
He's gonna...
Yeah, he might be the most boring guy.
Alive, he might be.
Father of two.
How's your kids?
Okay, my only suspicions, my only suspicions is that he is
born in 1968.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, it seems legit, seems legit.
He has two kids.
Yeah, yeah, I think it's legit.
I think it's legit.
Okay.
He's just boring.
Yeah.
See you, John Smith.
Basically.
Okay.
Freaking rat.
Stop it!
Hello!
Hey!
Uh, toilet paper, toilet paper!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Yeah, get out of here!
Yeah!
They start to bleed, but don't worry about it.
Hey there, Night Owl.
You look like you could use a trick.
I am already...
Ready, suspicious.
Caught stealing.
I didn't take anything.
Stop harassing me.
Give ya.
Back away, asshole.
I already told you I didn't take anything.
What the?
What?
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
How are we supposed to non-lethally take care of these
people?
There's someone graffitiing outside!
Poor paper!
Graffiti!
What's the waiting room?
Where do you get the toilet paper from?
Need to clean up their blood?
In the bathroom.
Oh, in the bathroom.
And I spend a lot of time staring at the toilet stalls,
so...
Okay, no worries.
Clean this up.
We can't kill the thieves.
We'll get fined, I think.
Yeah, we get fined for killing people.
So- Only there wasn't a fine.
I know, right?
I'm be fine killing people normally.
There's also trash everywhere.
How you feeling, Vicky, about this lady?
think she's okay the one thing that's kind of like confusing
me which i know is probably nothing like the outline is like
bigger than her head oh that's not an anomaly right i don't
think so oh my god quit it lady i think i think she's fine
though i think so i mean we need the money guys If you think
so, I'll trust you.
I don't know.
Are we gonna do the thing where we just accept everyone?
Oh.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, oh, oh.
There's a freaking...
Oh, Iwo!
Did you see that?
There's a guy crawling on the ceiling.
No, I didn't see!
Yeah.
Oh, we're gonna throw toilet paper at the guy crawling on
the ceiling, causing trouble.
Oh, my God.
Is he really throwing?
Yeah.
Where is he?
Shit at midnight.
What is this?
What?
Did you guys put a shit at midnight poster?
on the wall oh yeah i did that sorry okay okay so this is
not bad that was a man this is sorry that was me i love it
though i love it it's okay
what was that what was that what was that what was it oh
that means someone was stealing that means someone was
stealing oh are they gone i don't see They must have left.
This guy?
No, wait.
No, he's coming in.
How's this person?
Wait.
Are you seeing?
Oh.
No.
That is not them.
Are you Doug?
My occupation?
No, I'm not unemployed.
I'm a hairdresser.
What do you think I actually took?
Wait, I think I actually took my twin's ID when heading out.
Is there anything you could do to double check my identity?
What's her name?
Kramer?
Last name Kramer.
Kramer.
Oh, occupation hairdresser.
Oh, oh, oh.
Hang on, she's not appearing.
She's not appearing on the anomaly thing.
She's like invisible.
Whoa!
Kill him.
Yeah.
Who's...
Whoa,
why is he brick dancing on her body?
Wow.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey!
Everything 100% off?
Who said that?
Why?
Excuse me?
Wake up!
Get out!
Yeah!
And stay out!
Hey mate!
Let me just get a 20 gates...
20...
Get...
20 dollars of gas, mate.
There's a lot of stuff in the back of his van.
I was struggling with that one, team.
My little girl, Dala's been begging me one for years.
Okay, what's your name, bro?
Does anyone know his name?
Uh...
No, but he's got a picture...
Douglas Dahlia and hold on I gotta ask him about this photo
the photograph oh you found that yeah that's me with my
adopted kids I don't think that's him I think we kill this
guy okay I trust you yep mr.
man is a little I think he's white I Oh god, that lady's
scared.
I took the gun.
It is a interesting noise, huh?
Really?
Hello?
It's not for this one from the rat, is it?
I took I- or I'm killing the rat.
Beard and hair?
Wow!
Oh, damn.
My twin sister, her name's Mia and she's getting married
soon.
Lisa, Ken.
Hello?
No more hats?
That means we can get endless money, guys!
What does that sound that?
Hey!
Hey, right, right, right, right, right.
That's true!
You okay?
This game is insane.
I tried to catch a thief.
I tried to catch a thief and then I didn't have anything to
cause damage for her so she just walked away after me.
She was like, it wouldn't be easier to just let me go.
Oh, how do I take care of this guy?
Alright, guys.
I'm taking care of our veterinary bills.
One spin at a time.
Alright.
Go.
Can I flush him down?
No more hats to unlock.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we just keep getting money.
So we can just keep spinning it for more dollars.
Oh, nice.
So we should be able to afford Shut the door, buddy.
Maybe the bat, yeah.
She said her twin sister is...
Huh?
Okay.
I think this is a sign.
And then Mia's her twin sister.
Okay, okay, okay, I see.
You're back, Snake!
Where are you going?
She's like your twin sister.
Wait, what?
What?
What is going on?
Ew!
Stop it!
Stop doing that!
I don't want to see my hero go to the bathroom.
There is a corpse in the bathroom, just don't worry about
it.
I am so high suspicious of this lady.
Yeah.
Oh, we've unlocked every single hat.
Yeah, we'll see.
Yeah.
Well, because she's asking what can she get for her twin
sister?
And then I look up her twin sister in the system, and they
don't have the same date of birth.
And when I click it, she's like, no, oh, no.
No, wait.
I mean, she's like my twin sister.
It feels we're so close.
She feels like a twin sister.
You know?
Mm.
Suspicious.
I agree.
All right, guys.
I got us a ton of money.
I think we shoot them.
I'm taking her.
Are we just...
But then are we going to just take everyone's money?
Is that the plan?
Did you scan her?
I did.
She looks okay in the scanner.
Yeah, she got that body-y-y-y-y thing, girl.
Um, I don't know.
Wait, no tattoos?
Though the sister has tattoos, guys.
She doesn't.
The sister's got tattoos.
Yeah.
Always wears her blue necklace.
Oh.
Sorry, I didn't mean to look at her ass.
I was looking at the dress pattern.
I thought it was blood, but it's no one.
Oh.
So should we just try then or what do we do?
I mean, I think at this point we need money, right?
So if we're not sure...
Real quick, come to the bathroom real fast.
Is it the corpse in the bathroom?
Yes.
You can't do anything about him.
I think the dentist left him as a warning and also broke the
mirror.
Oh, man.
No, the necklace is definitely there, guys.
Yeah.
I reckon we just take her money if we're not sure because
okay I mean we are pretty sure though aren't we I'm sure I
don't know I'll just take it I'll take it we need the money
we need excuse me why people littering everywhere oh it's
okay I got it yeah I know they're being so rude today I'm
gonna
grab this toilet paper ready to throw any nuisance makers
here's something Somebody got the four-star review for us,
but everything that they said was nice.
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to throw that at you, bro.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
He's fine, he's fine.
Oh, oh, he's okay, probably.
Isaac Warren.
His, oh, I remember this guy from before because his
necklace was upside down before, but it's fine this time.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm double checking for, like, any vandals and of the such.
Uh, you, nothing around.
Things seem fine.
For now.
You okay on the scanner, bro?
Yeah, you seem fine.
I think he's okay.
Yeah?
Aha, there you are, you rascal.
Yes, I think so.
I think he's alright.
Okay.
I trust you.
Should I let him go?
Yeah, take him.
Certainly looks like...
Youth cluster, where's the last time?
Yeah.
Yeah, last time you definitely...
Can you just fart?
Um, um, excuse me!
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Hey!
Help me!
Where is he?
He's chasing me!
I have no weapon!
There!
I think we gotta kill him!
It's Vista!
It's the...
Wait, it's the...
Okay, I think we gotta kill him, yeah?
I gotta...
Wait.
Owie!
Ow!
Holy cow!
oh whoa it's the detective it's victor yeah why did he start
coming after us like that oh is it is it because we
befriended those other dudes oh he was like why did you do
it why did you do it what did we do listen we may we may
have befriended the you know the summoning circle people but
they were cool oh oh wait there's still a guy in here though
oh he's you let one doppelganger completed transaction it
might have been the twin yeah we did well we needed money
when do we get Phoebe stop re-stocking the shelves when the
exit is coming okay this ain't right this ain't right oh you
got a landmine nice
anymore i can never find any of the wood i know the wood i
don't think we have anymore is the issue oh i'll get dropped
now grab this this bad boy for you let's at least close that
door yeah closing it sounds nice all right all right let's
do this let's do this we'll be fine guys we'll be fine I'm
kind of injured though because of the guy.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, see?
Oh, not really.
Watch out, Phoebe.
I'm gonna grenade him.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, shit!
What is that?
There's a guy?
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
He can't attack him at all.
I think he's...
Yeah, he's...
Oh.
Jack-in-the-box.
I got it.
I got the jack-in-the-box.
Nice.
You're down?
Oh, the guy is coming down.
Oh, the guy only moves when you're not looking at him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Someone has to always be looking at this guy.
I hear the jack-in- oh, I got it.
Nice.
Uh-oh.
Okay, so why is it not?
Why can't I slap him?
I'm gonna...
Oh, I can.
Watch out.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
I'm out of him.
Oh, sorry.
How much health does this dude have?
Yeah.
Thank you.
I just keep whacking him and then dying and then repeating
the process.
Just keep looking at him.
I'll, uh, shotgun.
Okay.
Oh, I'm out of ammo entirely.
Oh, someone get the jack-in-the-box, please.
Where is it?
Oh, jack-in-the-box.
I'll keep looking.
Oh, oh, oh, no.
Oh, I was looking at him.
No, where is it?
I don't see.
Oh, okay.
Where is it?
I got it.
I'm still looking.
Can we not?
I think you need traps.
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
It said, um, hold on.
Hold on.
Uh, okay.
I'm gonna put this here.
And then everybody...
You guys walk away.
Yeah, you guys walk away and I'll lead him towards me.
So you guys go away.
Vicky, that means you too.
So like, go away and don't look at him?
He's this stall.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going away.
Okay, okay.
Is this good?
Can I get more ammo?
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh, he's trapped now.
Can we kill him?
Oh.
Someone get the Jack in the Box!
That's why Jack in the Box.
Here, where are you?
Okay, where are you?
I can never find them.
Oh, I'm gonna, I'm gonna.
Oh, no.
Uh-oh.
Oh, oh, sure.
Oh, no.
No!
What is that?
I don't...
Oh no.
Ah!
It's on me!
What?
Guys, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Oh, I lived.
I lived.
Holy shit.
Whoa.
You lived.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Okay.
So now we just need to sort this guy out.
We just keep trapping this guy.
Yeah.
So do the same thing.
I'll do the same thing.
So I'll like alert him.
I'll like...
Yeah.
So you look away.
You guys walk away and I'll just keep leading him in the
trash.
Okay, walk away?
Okay.
Yeah.
You just be on the lookout for a...
Oh, yay!
We got him!
Yeah!
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, the whole place is so nice.
Yeah.
Oh, it is a nice place.
Oh, disgusting.
Disgusting.
The roach... What the roach is going from as well?
Guys, if you smack the guy in the bathroom with a bat, does
he turn into little pieces?
No, I've tried already.
Yeah, he doesn't.
Holy cow.
Come here, you!
Oh, gross.
You got it, thanks.
Oh, the rat!
Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh, more body.
More bodies.
Why are there so many body parts?
Oh, that was scary, guys.
And you want to clean up?
I'm gonna go throw this in though.
Clean up.
Everybody everywhere.
My friends out there having a good day.
Oh, I'm picking it up.
Wait, you guys have gone to the boss already?
No, I haven't.
Yeah.
Holy cow, that was stress.
That was something.
That was the worst night.
I know.
That was pretty bad.
I mean, we are getting to near the end of the game, so...
Yeah.
Oh, I can heal.
Oh, wait.
Come in.
I can heal you guys.
You don't want to be healed?
Oh, yeah.
Did you get, like, a bandage thing?
Do so.
I think I healed Stevie.
I have no idea.
I think we heal every time we finish, though, no?
Oh, oh, sure.
I know I've done that.
Oh, well.
It's okay.
I think we're good.
How many days have we got?
All two, all two.
How much money?
Days have we got?
We got two more days after this, so...
It's okay, though.
We can do it.
Even if we took that guy's money or let him free, it's fine
because we got the money for our pet, right?
We still need...
Oh my gosh.
We need like $28 at least each day.
time like we need gotta to get to 250 oh my god oh my god
take everyone's money yeah we gotta get oh my gosh oof oof
oof oof let them all through okay it is it was the twin
thing it was the twin thing i see oh my gosh they're so
specific guys we got this guys we got this yeah we do for
goose
All right.
It's a new night.
We gotta... We can keep spinning, yeah.
Keep spinning to winning.
Yeah, I think just like, because now that we've got all the
hats, you can just keep spinning.
Every time we have money.
Yeah.
So we'll just keep getting money, yeah.
I can't believe we have all the hats.
That's crazy.
Oh, someone cleaned the body.
That's good.
Oh, good.
Someone cleaned the body.
10 bucks Money, money, money, money If you do that, then you
get You get a few coins back at least Nice Oh my god
At least it refunds you That's nice Oh, oh, 10 coins is good
Yeah, nice Here I'll grab some more too Whatever I find Oh,
there's one oh sorry my apologies no no you're totally fine
oh oh oh oh i don't trust i got i oh no oh missing dog guys
reward fifty dollars reward fifty dollars that's huge don't
we need fifty Yellow collar.
Yellow collar.
Call if you have any info.
Okay, we'll keep an eye out.
Yeah, that's you.
Oh, this guy is covered in blood.
Doggo, are you out here?
Do you want goose to live?
You cannot afford surgery.
Can you call the sheriff tonight?
Convince him to visit the store tomorrow.
Goose will live a long life.
Are we sacrificing the sheriff for the goose?
Oh.
Whoa, we got to make that decision.
Oh, my gosh.
Beatroot farmer.
Will we sacrifice now?
Yeah, that's me and his son will bake up my own goodies in
the fields all day.
I think we can make the money without sacrificing anything.
I think so, too.
I think we should have enough.
Okay, so spending this money doesn't affect the personal
funds we have towards surgery.
Right, because it says it's the store balance.
So, yeah, I think we're good.
I'm going to get the backpacks.
that'll be okay yeah chainsaw let's go
but in that wood in the back for later i grow real food i
want to feed half the stuff on the shelves to my hogs but
you have a lot of blood on you yeah what what kind of farmer
is this guy a beetroot yeah so it kind of makes sense be
true huh he doesn't have a toothpick though in his mouth.
It says he always has one.
What's a toothpick?
He seems fine on the scanner at least.
We have to kill him.
He doesn't know what a toothpick is.
Yeah, he needs to know what it is.
Arr, you son of a bitch.
So sorry.
Sorry about that.
What was that?
What the heck was that?
What was it?
There's someone going, I heard that too.
I thought it was just me.
Okay.
Just checking if it's the dog.
No, that doesn't seem like it.
I should not be spraying the computer, but I had to.
Ew!
Hey, keep the money.
Keep getting the money.
Need the money.
Half asleep.
Hi, don't mind me.
I'm half asleep.
Don't mind me.
Yasmin.
Trinket seller.
She's a trinket seller.
You can find my handmade jewelry at the local flea market.
Oh, that's kind of fun.
Always wears gold jewelry.
She is wearing gold jewelry.
Always wears.
Wait, no.
She's not wearing it in the scanner.
Scorpio gazing.
I need to look up some Zoriac stuff.
Her jewelry doesn't show up in the scanner.
Oh, it's fake jewelry.
It's fake.
It's not gold.
Oh, man.
We're not going to make money if we don't have...
People to...
I don't know.
Yeah, what the heck?
I'm trying to make some dollars back here at the moment.
I'll let you know how it goes.
Yeah, thanks.
Oh, we have a car out there too.
Look.
Get out of here.
Hello?
Evening cutie pie.
I'd like $14 of cash.
Handsome.
Yeah, definitely.
Definitely not suspicious.
Is there something red out out there?
Am I crazy?
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Madison Gray.
Kind of feels like that, doesn't it?
QPB6.
QPB.
six that's a 95 multiple travel related bumper stickers yeah
we got the okay yeah yeah she went all over okay so madison
gray huh madison gray no littering no loitering deceased
hiking accident oh man that's our third person tonight i
think we're gonna have to start that I keep my hiking stuff
in there.
We should go sometime.
Oops, I'm supposed... I suppose you got all my details.
Would be rude to not contact me now.
I'm watching you.
Well, they're doing it right now in front of you, Phoebe.
Oh!
Oh, with me in the stall, too!
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm gonna...
I think they got us like $50.
Really?
Wow.
Oh, you did?
Wow, nice!
this lady because she only has she only is asking for like
15 for 18 i'm not gonna you know no we ain't worth it anyone
who's spending big maybe we can let them yeah i think that
right excuse me excuse me hey um hey who are these don't
look at dog bones hey hey hey get out of there
hey oh they're smacking me
hey stop i can't hear you oh you good Okay.
Yeah, I think we're good.
I think we're good.
We got him.
Oh, my God.
Jeez.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, I think you could say that again.
Trey.
Could say that again, Trey.
Scuba diving instructor.
Red eye tattoo on his left hand.
Yeah, he's got that.
What's happening at the supermarket?
You...
You, we both.
I wanted to match with my girlfriend, Lisa Carver.
Oh.
Ew, my god, why don't these people shut the door at least?
Oh, I'm washing your ass.
You don't even wash your hands.
Jeez, Louise.
This is paper.
Sorry, what was the girlfriend's name?
Lisa Carver?
I hardly even know her.
That is not a name.
There is Linda Carver or Lisa Cannon, but there is no Lisa
Carver.
Uh-oh.
Oh, my gosh.
We have no...
Our quota is $80.
But maybe it's his like...
Pretend girlfriend.
He is thinking of Linda Carver who has a red eye tattoo on
her left hand, not Lisa.
Doppelganger.
He doesn't even know his girlfriend's name.
Yeah, he's a doppelganger.
Bad boyfriend.
Is that all it's gonna say?
It's gonna be like, no, wasn't a doppelganger, just a bad
boyfriend.
Bad boyfriends deserve death, I guess, in this game.
bad boyfriend is death penalty in this game you guys yeah
get him he made up a fake girlfriend who lives in canada who
would do that use the screen scan true true true oh oh um
bro can you right we need a toilet paper out there's someone
break dancing again again if you if you truly think he
deserves the death penalty well actually are we are we gonna
start accepting everyone now because of money let's see how
much he's buying let's see how much he's buying 27 oh i
think we should just take that's quite a lot actually that's
quite a lot isn't it right yeah you better learn your
girlfriend's name oh are we taking it oh it feels bad though
it's so it's so hard to know isn't it like but harbour and
goose I know.
Yeah.
What do you think we should do, chat?
And I don't want to have to sacrifice the sheriff either.
Alright, let's take it for the pets.
Yeah.
I agree.
We can learn your girlfriend's name!
We can live here.
I'll try and buy us more health or something.
Um, extra HP.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, string lines.
Wow, I love this style.
Good fashion.
Another shotgun, another flamethrower.
Um.
Oh, that.
Sounds like some goats.
What was that?
See what happens, I guess.
Seems fine on the scanner, this lady.
Well, how long have they been dating?
You should start dating someone if you don't know their
name.
Ah!
You!
Imani Green.
Don't call the cops.
I just, I just needed something to eat, alright?
Give me back the items.
My cat needs to eat.
I mean my goose.
You're not going to hurt me.
Wait, I'll put a bow back.
I'm sorry.
I live alone.
Ah!
Guys, I don't mean to alarm you, but the dentist...
Yes.
The dentist is in our...
In our...
Oh.
What was that?
I'm going to let this lady through.
Take the money.
Oh my god.
You asshole!
Oh.
I scared him off.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Oh, you scared him?
Yeah, but he delivered us a bunch of body parts.
Oh, thank you so much.
How kind.
How kind that is.
Yeah.
How can you close the door when you're using the toilet at
the very least?
Wait, this is the actual delivery?
Bless you.
Do you know where I...
Thank you.
Where I can get training cards for my son.
Oh, he's a Pokemon.
GCG scalper.
You say it's for your son, but I bet it's not for your son.
I trust it.
We can look up if he has a son.
True.
Evan Walker.
Yeah.
Wait, where's the third one?
Tom Walker.
How old is Tom Walker?
1987 unemployed.
Yeah, that does check out, actually.
That does check out.
Oh, never mind.
Sorry for calling you a scalper I'm just traumatized I'm
cleaning up the place although have we scanned them yet oh
I'll do that it looks all right actually I don't think he is
a scalper actually I think he's all right hey wait there's a
guy standing right next to you smoking oh wait get out of
here okay sorry man you can't you can't let him get away
with it i'm sorry i'm sorry to be fair if it was if it was
shadow the head troll i'd probably right i mean wait did
someone order something or is this dead bodies again oh it's
an explosive oh okay awesome thank you Thank you.
Oh.
Is this guy okay?
Are we letting him go?
He seems to get...
He was.
We scanned him and I checked.
He does have a son, so I think it's okay.
Limbs can be destroyed.
Yeah, I know, but...
I didn't have anything to destroy.
Put on some pants, brother.
Please.
I think he's alright.
Yeah, he seems normal.
Yeah, let's let him go.
I was looking for dog No dog though this guy Yeah, the dog
would be good Would the dog be one of these boxes?
Dog in the box.
Oh my gosh.
There's trash everywhere.
I'm gonna look outside again for dogs.
Hello.
Hello Hey, let me just grab these things Karen Whitfield
Real estate agent.
Yeah, but damn good one as well.
One signature away from a million dollar closing.
They're little reminders of what hard work looks like in
metal form.
Let me scan your body.
Adi, Adi, Mrs.
I'm going to go double check with the flashlight for the dog
outside.
Okay.
I don't think there's a dog anywhere at the moment.
I haven't seen dog either.
November baby 28 years old
blonde slicked bag it's part of the uniform maybe the dog
will be in someone's car I can't suck at work all day this
is the huge deal hmm isn't this the same person who came in
and was fake or was that just someone else born with a
ponytail was there somebody fake with her it was someone
else blonde with a ponytail oh okay she seems good so I'm
gonna check her out where is gold jewelry yeah she did yeah
she said fine she did oh yeah i know i know we definitely
let we definitely did yeah yeah i was with that one guy dog
though i know we never saw the dog and the fire also oh dude
okay all right let's get this going oh
where's all of our Oh, there's some on the back that I just
used.
How does this explosive work?
Oh, okay.
What?
Are you restocking?
Phoebe, stop stalking Michelle!
I'm not stalking!
I'm putting the poop!
Oh, there's another nade right here if you want one.
If I have to hide in the stall, I don't want there to be
poopy.
There's a nade for somebody if they want.
Oh, oh, where?
In here, where the guns are.
stuff right here right here right here yeah yeah did you did
you lay the trap oh wait I did yeah I
missed it I missed it oh shoot man oh my god gosh they're
aggressive They're so aggressive.
Ah, I hear music box!
Is it in the room?
I got it.
Yeah.
If we can lead into the fire room, I can detonate.
Oh.
I love the flamethrower.
Okay, but dog, where?
Yeah.
Yeah, dog, where?
Dog where?
We tried finding him.
What is that?
Yeah, we walked.
Oh, I just threw the things back down.
Oh, okay.
That's a lot of meat.
Maybe in the forest, but we can only go to the forest
sometimes.
Yeah.
Yeah, it wasn't open.
Take out the trash and have a look, but...
I know.
I've been looking around all night for them.
Scared.
me yeah are you okay yeah just bear trap normal everyday
stuff yeah i get it i get it does someone want to make a
note of the phone number in case they change it but he turns
up oh i'm gonna take a picture of this chat yeah five five
five nine eight three two three three and don't get it wrong
unless you want all our pets to die yeah take note five five
five nine eight three 233 we're relying on you yeah and we
also went gear mill to get home yes all right we're so close
guys good job guys we're so close we can do it except Senya
you got it wrong oh are we good?
are we leaving?
my bad i'm coming
Come on.
Oh, any dogs?
No dogs.
Oh, dog somewhere.
Oh, dog.
All right.
We're doing good, guys.
We're doing real good.
Yeah, we know we let in a few.
Yeah, we do know we let in that one guy.
Okay.
I don't think our revenue was as high today, though,
unfortunately.
Wait, we got $29.
That's more than yesterday.
Yay!
Yeah, I think we're...
Oh.
We can do this.
The last day.
Tomorrow, do we just accept everybody?
I think, I don't even know if we need to.
Oh, today's shift, you received an email.
It claimed that if you call the sheriff and have him visit
the store tomorrow, Goose's surgery cost will be covered.
I say...
Don't call him.
I think, I think we're okay.
Yeah.
I don't want to put him at risk.
Yeah, I think we're all right.
We can do it.
I know, I know that that must be bad.
That's surely bad end, isn't it?
Sure.
Cool and Clyde.
Oh, it's really clinging on to laugh!
No!
Herbert!
We can make it, guys.
It'll be alright.
Well, we didn't kill the sheriff.
That was a doppelganger.
Yeah.
It was a doppelganger.
We knew this guy was a doppelganger too.
Her name is Linda.
Yep.
You called it.
Yeah.
desperate for money, you guys.
I know, we are.
We let that guy on purpose, but we got good money for it, so
I think it's worth.
Yeah, I think worth, worth.
Sometimes you gotta let some people through the cracks, you
know?
Why can't they take an I-O-U?
Wait, did I click next year?
Yeah.
Driver Dade.
Did I click?
Wait, who didn't?
Who didn't click?
Phoebe?
I think Phoebe might be eating.
Oh.
No, no, no, I'm not eating, but I could be eating.
already several times yeah me too are there me too uh-oh oh
oh oh no no way did it hello if we truly if we leave and
rejoin it'll work right i think will it let us leave because
it's not like i click escape and nothing's happening oh no
no no no No, no, no, no, no, no.
Is there a save button usually or does it auto save?
I think it auto saves after every shift.
It should?
It should.
But then hopefully this counts as after shift.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, well we can at least attempt.
We can at least attempt to quit the game and rejoin.
There's nothing we can do.
There's nothing, yeah.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Oh my gosh, no.
i'll send you guys another invite see you on the other side
see you in a bit
oh it's painful to do okay that's what we got to do though
guys shift at midnight oh man as long as it saved everything
up till now i think it's okay i mean we can if it if it
makes us redo that one day that's not the end of the world
but It's 9-13!
We're okay, we're okay!
We're okay!
I know that, but they don't know that.
I know that.
They'll know that soon.
We are okay!
We're okay!
Yeah, it says night 13.
We're all right.
Oh, thank goodness.
Yeah.
Tiki?
Yuppie.
Yuppie!
I'm gonna eat a snack real quick.
I'm getting hungry.
Yeah, go ahead.
Welcome back.
Ahoy, ahoy.
Tiki?
We can't hear you.
you if you're talking yeah i got goldfish
try rejoining vicky oh there you are there you are me my me
me me me me my can you hear me now yeah yeah okay awesome
awesome all right we're good to go i'm ready i'm ready to go
last night oh we got this we got We got this.
For Suki!
What was it?
Hubert?
Herbert?
And Goose?
Alright!
What is this?
Oh.
Gold coins, gold coins.
Oh wow, look at all these gold coins.
There's so many gold coins.
Lots and lots of gold coins.
Yeah.
Mayor Dawson's death.
The day marks 45 years since the untimely suicide of the
greatly celebrated Mayor Bill Dawson remembered for his
selflessness and the love he showed throughout his time and
time.
Gold coins, gold coins.
I pick up those gold coins.
Any friends in the woods today?
No one out here to play.
Gold coins, gold coins.
Eat them up, bottom gold coins.
Actually, don't eat them because they're not chocolate.
Eat them up.
They're just regular gold coins Gold coins Gold coins We'll
get them to save our pets coins And we'll get lots of money
from these gold gold coins I think we need some gold coins I
think we need some Did you guys, I love those gold coins
that are actually chocolate Wait what happened?
I want nothing Me too, they're so awesome Something about
them just tastes better than regular chocolate.
Probably because they're gold coins.
Yeah, the gold...
They say so good.
What is this?
45 years since beloved Mayor Dawson's death.
Wait, that guy looks like the dentist.
Wait.
That's the mayor?
The lore is coming out.
Oh, that's 45 years since our beloved...
Beloved Mayor Dawson's.
Okay.
Well, there's a car outside already.
And there's a guy going to the bathroom.
Untimely suicide.
Sir?
What?
No!
Dingus?
Away!
Ugh.
I knew you were up to no good.
Okay, I need to grab some fruit for my roommate.
You know, if any stores are selling it this late.
Guys, customers have begun to leave without paying if they
wait too long for service.
Customers have more patience if the store rating is high.
If a doppelganger's presence, patience runs empty, it will
alert the entity.
All right, we gotta be...
Oh, shoot.
Oh, she's got a patience bar.
Okay.
She does?
There's a car outside as well.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll get the car.
I'll get the car.
Hey there.
$12 of gas.
Okay.
I don't know if the cars also have a patience
Doesn't seem like it though.
Wait, does it?
I can't tell.
Oh, you are okay We're not letting we're not letting
entities through right.
I guess for money purposes.
We're just gonna I think you could do it right now
She lived alone, but she was talking about a roommate nine
one G's oh J nine G-J.
White mini-biams.
Good.
I should check out boxes.
I just got fired from my job bringing all my belongings home
now.
Filing cabinets.
I just got fired.
Oh my gosh.
So I said screw them and took the whole filing cabinets
home.
You know what?
I'm going to let you go because that's awesome.
She got fired so she stole all of the filing cabinets.
she just that's amazing yeah she deserves to go free i agree
yeah it's pretty funny not a fan of the clothes blah blah
blah thanks
that's so funny what a funny thing for a human or
doppelganger to do whoa big man i think i remember this guy
Tall.
Yeah.
Holy DARPA chief.
Oh, wow.
Grabbing a few things before heading back on the road.
Okay, Kevin.
Oh, no problem.
Tall.
Was that noise?
Often informal wear.
Just blessed.
Blessed with good genes.
Always professional.
You seem like a pretty professional guy in me.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
Yeah!
He deserves to go.
Oh, yeah.
To the club.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Should I kill him?
Yeah.
Oh, I kind of don't want to, you know.
How much money is he giving us?
25 bucks.
Yeah, let's let him go.
He's got the moves.
You know, don't you agree?
Yeah.
He's got the moves.
You know, if you're going to be a doppelganger.
Be a fun doppelganger.
Whoa!
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
It's an invasion!
Let's roll the paper!
It's a Meiwaku invasion!
Meiwaku!
Oh my god!
Meiwaku invasion!
Hello friend, you look tired.
I hope your night is gentle.
Sorry!
Oh, I didn't mean to throw that at you!
I'm sorry!
Who's sleeping and where are they sleeping?
there hey get out of our oh my god there's so many people in
the back this patient's bar is still okay so far um okay
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool though what not gonna
lie i kind of aspire to that oh thank you so much thank you
so much she was lifting the whole hegan combini shelf
Oh, there's like trash everywhere now, too.
Oh, that's an explosive.
Okay, hello, sir.
Hello, my friend.
You apply.
I hope your night is gentle.
Thank you.
The big birthmark.
But even if flower grow with strange color, it is still
flower.
My mother told me there's many flowers.
Okay.
What?
What does that mean?
A tree of all color.
Flores.
flower's head becomes quiet i like quiet um wait oh he does
have oh i thought it was blood oh he's running out of time
march 14th oh that's so nice a florist is he is he seeing
fine lovely well let's scan him real quick i think so yeah
i'm scanning i don't see anything yeah i didn't see him
either anything either so i think he's okay i think he's
running out of patience yeah oh did he did you do it yeah
okay good okay good job baby good job awesome oh just barely
um sorry what do you have there this guy has a gun just fyi
oh yeah this lady is wow way she's like a filter holy cow i
bought decor so we can put it up put the I'm nervous, I'm
only here for supplies.
You're a different Dimitri.
Hunter.
Hunter, gold piercing on left ear often carries a rifle.
You've got a gun too.
You don't see me interrogating you about it.
Okay buddy, okay buddy.
You got the earring?
He does not have an, oh wait, the earring is on his right
ear.
It's supposed to be on his left ear.
Ah!
Oh yeah it is, it is on the, it is on the Yeah.
He was mean so I'm gonna...
I'm gonna shoot him because he was mean.
Yeah.
La la la la.
La la la la la la la la la la la.
Oh, oh, sorry, Phoebe.
Whoops.
Oh, it's okay.
Sorry.
Nope, no, you...
I...
I hit you.
Oh, I did get hit.
It was okay.
Oh, this is the...
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Her signature is like horns and a tail.
11th of August.
Fake.
You're fake.
She's fake.
How do you know?
Why?
Different birthday.
Oh, yeah!
Regularly.
I beg of you.
Oh.
Guy, what was she begging for?
No, I was begging this person to poop normally and they
didn't.
Oh.
Oh, oh, I see.
Ah!
Um, um.
Um.
You okay?
Uh, watch out, Veeby.
Watch out.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, hello.
Okay.
Oh, wait, I've seen you before.
We've seen you before, huh?
This is the dentist.
Wait, I'm the mayor!
Hi.
Wait, he has Clyde's.
No.
You guys, he has Clyde's.
He has the sheriff's.
He has the sheriff's, uh...
I...
Why do you have the sheriff's?
I have this.
Should we use it?
She's got a chainsaw.
A chainsaw.
The music stopped.
What do we do?
Yeah, the music stopped.
Do we just attack?
Is it time to finally take him down?
I think we could.
I think we can take him.
Let's be prepared first.
We got weapons.
Grab some health stuff too for yourself.
Yeah, grab like a first aid kit.
Come see this painting in the back, guys.
Come see this painting in the back.
Yeah, it sure is something, huh?
Yeah, it's a little freaky.
I feel like we just gotta...
Gotta kill him.
It's time.
Okay.
I've just got melee.
I just got this bat.
I'm gonna blow up on him.
Okay, we're gonna get out of the way.
Alright, here I go.
Three, two, one.
Oh.
Oh!
Guys, I think we gotta go!
I think we gotta go!
Okay, we're going, we're going.
Oh, what's happening?
Oh, I'm getting absorbed by the walls, guys.
Oh!
Oh, not.
Whoa!
Ah!
Okay, hello?
Run!
Run where?
Oh, there.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Ah!
Oh, that's it.
Oh!
I got it!
Oh, okay.
Oops.
We're five, we're five.
Everything's good.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Yeah, we can do this, guys.
We got to get a lot of money for this day.
Run!
Oh, the doors stay open.
Oh, yeah, that is nice.
Let's go to the left here, I believe.
Oh.
Left?
Yeah.
Whoops, I died.
Ah!
Oh shit, I died.
Do we get like endless lives here or what?
Maybe, it seems like it.
Yeah, third time's a charm, guys.
It worries.
Who was that running into the wall?
So much for the door saying all of
them.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can't make this.
dang thing when it when it first started i ran straight into
him i ran the wrong way i literally ran me too we got this
you guys yeah okay niki run
oh my
god i hit it every time oh go go
we got this we got this guys we got this we got this Oh my
gosh.
We got this.
Are we watching Groundhog Day?
Yeah, very good.
Guys, we got this, believe.
It's not horror Groundhog Day.
We've got this.
Why am I so- Totally got this.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Oh, no!
We're never gonna beat the game!
For goose, for turkey, and Herbert.
Herbert!
You know, I'm disappointed we didn't see the gnome again.
Yeah, I'm disappointed too.
We only saw him that one time.
Yeah, right?
No.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, dang it, I died.
Go, go, go.
Go!
Oh, no.
Made it.
Who's the one who made it?
Phoebe.
Oh.
Phoebe, good job.
Good job, Phoebe.
Good job.
You hurt so bad, but...
But well done.
We did it.
Your shift is done.
Clean up any... Come on, there's gotta be...
I hope we made enough money.
Yeah, I hope so.
I really hope we made enough money.
Well, here, let's clean up some rats and stuff.
Our revenue today was so small.
Yeah, if you clean, if you clean, you can make more money.
So...
quick question should we just try cooling the number with
the dog i mean just and then maybe we'll get the money even
though we haven't seen the dog just to try do it do it
that'd be funny okay oh we can't no one is cooling are we
not cool um
oh we should have lied yesterday oh well it's fine do we
gamble then does this money count towards our money it it
does but we don't have enough we don't enough yeah i've been
i've been i've been spinning every time to try and get as
much money as possible so hopefully we have enough but we're
at 92 dollars all we need is 17 of that so we might it might
be giddy giddy but we might do it maybe i believe in hope so
i believe in hope so oh i got more 10 more cents let's go
come on can i get to 93 do earn some last last minute money
can we get 93 dollars 93 93 93 can we sell these freebies
like this guy yeah right no yeah can we oh i wish the game
had really said like that we would have a shorter shift or
something you know like yeah then we then we should have
just let everyone through yeah exactly Oh no.
Oh, I really hope we have enough.
I hope we have enough.
Oh guys, I don't think there's anything else we can do
really.
I think we just gotta...
What is this?
I think we just gotta go for it.
I think so.
Can we sell stuff in the store?
No, right?
That'd be nice.
No.
All sales final.
Let's hope we've got enough.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, there was some trash?
Where?
where chat where i see a grenade but i don't see trash
should we just oh can we put these in the trash whatever
these are should we just put it's the last day should we
just put everything in the trash wait you had a bag of trash
though was it full did it have any trash in it no oh what if
you just try and take out a bag without anything in it we're
so desperate oh plus zero We're so desperate.
Is there any like single coin somewhere a coin?
A coin a coin a coin penny for your thoughts Penny for your
thoughts.
Oh, I found a coin.
I found a token.
I found a token Oh wait, Vicky you should do it.
You should do it me Okay, yeah, you moment of truth you've
been spinning you've been spinning I believe
Okay, no bad, no bad, no bad, no bad, no bad Okay, someone
go this time, someone go this time You can do it, guys I
believe, I believe we can get that $10 Oh, my luck is really
bad That mine is too I'll try it though Alright, go, go, go
Okay, one more, one more One more, one more, one more.
Go on, Phoebe.
That's all we have.
We don't have enough to spin again.
That's okay.
We got $10.
We did good, though.
Yeah.
We did good.
Phoebe!
Oh, guys.
Can we save our pets?
Can we save?
Is $100 enough?
Oh, I hope so.
Wait, there's another coin here.
Do we have...
How many coins did we have?
Two?
I think we only had two.
Yeah, we need five.
Yeah, that's okay.
That's okay.
I think what will be will be.
Did you take the bobblehead?
I'm taking the bobblehead.
Did I take it?
What?
I'm taking the bobblehead.
What does that mean?
Oh, yeah, take it.
And the burger.
Mine.
Got to collectively hope and wish that everything will be
fine.
Oh, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on,
come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come
on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on,
on, come on, I don't think we would have if we had it, I
don't know, would we have done it without the $10, maybe we
had it.
pay the bill you keep true ending true ending
after weeks of desperately scraping together the money you
finally earned enough for Goose's life saving surgery the
operation was a success you feel your chest loosen oh thank
god and look we're getting we're getting a beer with Clyde
as well that's lovely oh oh oh oh Oh.
Clyde Dawson still drops right from time to time, bringing
cheap beer and old stories.
You never mention what you saw during that final night at
the gas station.
Oh.
Oh, that's lovely.
This save file has changed to post-story mode.
You may continue playing endlessly.
Suki will join you in all further future ships.
Yeah!
Wait, that is so crazy that if we had them spinned for that
last ten dollars.
Oh my god, they're all here!
Herbert's a key goose!
We did it!
Wait, don't let them out of the forest.
Oh!
Huh?
Oh.
Hi!
I think there's...
I think there's new guys to shoot or something.
Hello!
Oh, they're moving.
Hi!
Hello.
Yeah, they're moving towards us.
Yeah, they are.
Oh.
They are?
Oh, slowly.
Oh, very slowly.
Yeah, very, very slowly.
Oh, we did great, guys.
We did great.
Yeah.
Good job.
We did it.
Very, very.
Thank you for your support, Chad.
Oh, what just happened?
I shot that guy in the forest.
Oh, no.
Did anything happen?
Yeah, he went.
I went back inside.
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, there's another...
Oh my gosh, wait, this is like, they're all over the place
now.
Oh.
I guess we have to always be keeping an eye out for that.
Yeah, that's freaky.
If we were to keep playing.
It's probably a good time to, yeah, just...
Oh, it's probably a good time to...
To...
Time to...
Oh, special.
Oh.
Oh, were we doing it here?
I think we're announcing that here, right?
Oh, we can put it up as a flyer in the store.
Flyer in the store?
Yeah.
Wait, what?
We could put our announcement up as a flyer.
Oh!
On the bulletin board!
On the bulletin board.
Wait, that's quite a good idea, actually.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, I didn't...
I don't think I saved the picture.
Hold on.
I just go find it.
Okay, okay.
Choto minute chat.
Let me know when you guys are ready.
I am not ready.
Me neither.
Oh.
Wait, is it the...
Is it just that that one picture that was posted?
The one picture that was posted, the yellow picture, just
make sure we're all on the same page.
Okay, the yellow picture, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, all right.
Okie dokie.
I'm gonna line up my game perfectly on the boards and board.
Oh, oh, wait, that's cute.
Hold on, let me do that too.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, that's the squirrels.
Oh, oh.
All right, let me know when you guys are ready.
Oh!
Sorry, I didn't mean to...
Sorry.
I was sliding like... I clicked back into the game.
Are we okay?
We're okay.
I'm ready now.
I'm ready.
You ready?
Alright.
Yeah!
Shall we?
Okay!
Three, two, one!
That's for hope for the day!
Yay!
supports suicide prevention um please join us this coming
friday september 11th at 3 p.m pacific 6 p.m eastern and
what time is that in japan good question uh like 7 a.m yeah
i think yeah yes If you want to hit some fun goals while
raising for good cause, you'd come join us.
And if not, if you just want to come hang vibe with us, then
that's fun too.
Yeah.
It'll be really, really fun.
There's going to be different segments of our stream.
And we haven't announced the milestones and stuff yet.
So keep an eye out for more information real soon.
Yeah.
It's going to be a super fun time.
that we can see you guys there and also double densetsu this
week yippee yippee yippee ed is for a double densetsu yeah
double densetsu yippee i'm so excited yeah oh we can raise
lots of money for a great cause together with you den she
yeah yes it'll be on the dense Then set to channel so please
keep an eye out and go and subscribe to it if you haven't
yet.
Yeah, subscribe, subscribe.
It's a chat channel.
Then set to channel.
There's been a lot of noise going on at this game.
some of you must have quit the game.
I won't quit the game.
I'm scared, right?
We'll still have to quit it before something bad happens.
Yeah, I'm gonna quit out at the game.
I'm curious though.
I'm curious, what's going on?
I know, right?
Well, thank you guys so much for joining us today on our
adventures.
Yeah, thank you, thank you guys!
We got the best possible ending, I think.
Oh, wait, is Vicky... I think Vicky left, right?
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, cool.
Wait, shit, her pet's still here though.
Her pet's still here, yeah, yeah.
Whoa.
Vicky?
I think she left.
Should we go back to Discord or should we...?
Oh, where are we should go back to Discord.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Bye.
See you.
Bye bye.
Quick to menu.
Discord.
Turned them up.
No, it's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Sorry.
Oh, no, it's okay.
Hello.
Sorry.
No, no, no, no, it's okay.
No worries.
I wasn't sure when we are going back.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay, yeah.
Yeah, so excited!
For this charity scene with you guys.
Yeah!
It'll be so fun.
Our shimbo for you and all you guys on Friday.
Yeah!
Any other...
Announcements before we head off?
I don't think so.
All righty.
Then we will see all of you then for the Hope for the Day
fundraiser.
Yay!
Awesome!
Thank you!
Hope you guys have a wonderful, wonderful rest of your day.
Thanks for hanging out.
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you all!
We will dance.
See you later!
Wait, I didn't realize...
I didn't realize that they were late.
leaving.
I thought we were going to talk after.
But we can talk.
I can't.
We're actually we actually were going to hang out a little
bit afterwards.
So I can't hang for so long.
But yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
We were going to like we were just going to hang out after.
So I think Phoebe is.
Oh no.
Wait.
Everybody left.
That's okay.
I was going to also eat before beforehand.
Nicely done.
the last coin and ten dollars came in clutch for real right
look forward to the fundraiser great to raise money for good
guys have an awesome night thank you dorko it's funny
because like i had this collab on my schedule i was like oh
we're gonna collab and then and then they were like wait
were we doing the fundraiser that day i was like no i think
we We were just gonna hang out.
Can I get a happy birthday for Takizo?
He soon put earlier.
Takizo!
I'm so sorry!
I'm so- Oh my god, I suck!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
I'm so sorry.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Sorry, that game is so chaotic.
It's sometimes so hard to re-chat with it, but...
We beat it, and we got the true end.
The parkour part was killing me.
And I should have known about that spider web since I saw...
I spectated somebody else doing it.
Really fun collab, by 100% beta this Friday.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Minto, tomorrow is my birthday, so the stream is a
fun early gift.
Cody, happy early birthday!
Unfortunately, I won't be streaming tomorrow.
Or the day after.
I'm getting my cat.
And I want to make sure that they kind of like fit in well,
you know.
I bet they designed that one corner to be anti-MVP.
I know, right?
So, I'm taking two days to let my kitty adjust.
And, and, and, uh, make sure that they're okay and yeah so
maybe i don't know i don't know maybe their personality what
if they like come in they're like they like i'm streaming
they're like and they're like and i'm like oh my god baby
don't i go thank you hope everything works out thank you me
too thank you so much thank you good boy thank you oh my
gosh thank you for the third ever super chat bad saying that
but it's so funny that it that it stays like that it's
important to have a lot of time with them at the store yeah
yeah yeah exactly i hope we can share pics when you feel
comfortable i will take a little bit of time to do so
because i want to you know i want to make sure that you know
if i don't want to like be too hasty you know because what
if the cat is like and really really really unhappy and i'm
like oh maybe they just don't like me or something and um
and all that so uh i'm just gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna yeah
allergic to something something happens i'm just gonna play
play it safe until um until we uh until we know everything's
okay Yeah, yeah.
But, of course, I will share pictures when I can.
When I can.
Or when I feel like it's okay.
I'm gonna grab a bite to eat and then I'll be back.
But I'll keep you guys updated, too.
How they're doing, everything.
How things are settling in.
Any funny stories.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ghost cat coming home for real for real I sure hope so I
sure hope so unless I think it was terribly terribly wrong
that would be so sad Grandma burger you know I had a burger
just the other day actually you know what I tried or I had a
place that I have not eaten in so so long I had shake shack
and you know what I feel like I feel like I've been sleeping
on shake shack so good.
Like, it's so yummy.
I felt like I was sleeping on them.
Shake Shack mentioned.
Ooh, I only had their burger.
I didn't have the shake.
I didn't have the shack.
I hope it's different than the lobe shack.
That's a little old place where you could get together.
But the shake shack is a little old place where you could
sip together does it beat culverts though okay my that's
what i had after concert a week couple weeks ago what i
really love is a nice okay some people will disagree with
this so this is just a preference of mine i love like a thin
patty that's nice and charred is anybody else with me is
Anybody else with me?
Vicky!
Vicky, why did you raid?
Why did you raid?
I'm gonna be talking to you in like a minute.
Obakas!
Fancy seeing you here.
Hello, hello.
Night parade.
Wait, that's so cute.
idle meeting yeah i'll see you i'll see you soon
but yeah that's my favorite type of burger and so i taste i
was like oh my gosh this is pretty dang good shake shack why
do i gotta shake him i don't know because he's so tall you
gotta shake him to make it to shrink him Shrink Shack!
Wait!
Then what if we shrink him with our powers?
Gotta try cake shake from Portillo's.
Shake with a chocolate cake blended in?
Portillo's.
I don't know if I've ever had that place.
I'm terrified to say I do miss the in and out fries.
I told you.
Is that what happened to you?
You don't want to know what happened to me.
I should get going though.
I should go get some food and I should go.
hang out with the girls so thank you guys thank you thank
you thank you thank you for the collab and the stream and i
will see you and i see you later thank you guys thank you
thank you thank you thank you lachaminto
lachaminto bye since
i won't be streaming the next few days i'll miss you guys i
have actually i i didn't mean for it to be so many collabs
next week or this coming week but it ended up being because
of the charity stream on friday and then also because of uh
because of i'm playing halo with berry and then i wasn't
gonna take off uh i was only gonna take off monday um just
as like a regularly scheduled rest day but um with cat i
wanted to allow it extra little time so um yeah yeah so um
yeah okay bye bye bye bye bye